welcome to this video playing Pasha from
the US let's see Kings Indian whom yard
line add a request to play the four
pawns attack okay let's do that but I
must admit that and I don't really know
this yeah here they play if I've right
but i have no knowledge none I know
there's also night d to the word
continuation maybe try that I mean if I
already know only know that we have it
there is me five and not much more
um here I know that 97 castles and ce4
is a move and that problem I need to do
this anyway
yeah do we do your play Bishop f3 here
really maybe you haven't then lets you
for b6 looks a bit passive okay so night
c4b 5 takes takes Knight a5 is ok for
black yes
let's see for beef I can also take on d6
maybe maybe this is so then then d 5 the
said Lister opens up lots of lines I get
the pier the piece back with e5 and in
the process I open up the bishop here
and and everything ok he's not taking
only five interesting the question is
however should i should i take here i
can also play d 6am could also be
possible yeah maybe he can opt ins the
right anyway where I should put it in
age five and then I go 95 and win now
yes years before though then I can take
I still take f6f 1095 ok this one
two today he take here and play a five
maybe to have Bishop f4 you to have
Bishop f4 or should I take first they're
probably not
queen d6 Bishop f4 and my ideas to take
g6 and play Bishop g5 am oh he just
ignores this and I'm ABS compensation or
something but no reason not to play it
yeah I never probably take g6 first
depends a bit way is going yeah I'll
take you six fours to the Sam also can
be useful here with them Rock do you one
do you wanna I have some ideas against
f7 ready if he goes queen before I can
take g6 take be eight and 95 and I'm
crashing through on f7 okay it's kind of
ring that so now I should probably take
may I distill this issue with 95 okay
take here first
no 95 years takes it Queen f7 wow that's
not hmm maybe this isn't so clear
actually with the Queen trade at the end
he will get the beep on now that's not
that's not totally clear it really isn't
but what else and what else Quincy six
maybe in this before okay let's do that
at least I will get one of his spawn cm
I'll be able to cover be to at least now
wonder why is d taking this seems
totally forced check is there some some
way to I wait wait wait i have rook f3
actually look f3 is this may be working
rook f3 with Luke age 3 coming time
morning one night can retreat okay
probably not working
okay very Jack museum maybe I can play
for for medium with this King on the
side of the board point up to g5 and
rook h7 checkmate g4s not on
I can do this rook h7 mate maybe can
play g5 maybe you can play g5 but the
nav and I don't have aged five I know I
can take the bishop black resigns who
and I still come up to the end but it is
working him it is working here I was
thinking this one maybe the idea was
that if he does that I'll take check
take the bishop with the check so I
thought that this was the only only try
kappa this this is this is the same
thing actually check ok and winning yeah
I actually thought that he should should
just move the bishop to to see three or
something and try to to use the poem by
g4s Winningham this is really winning
this mating idea the threat is I go up
to age three and then g5 Luke h7 check
made yeah it is it is plus 6 according
to the comp so I'm probably winning the
bishop somehow due to the made threats
who this was complicated I was I wasn't
sure here really if there is something
better check yeah but it was the best
continuation yeah 26 was we had played
this rather quickly they're not it's not
necessary that could the computer wants
to do this and calls it equal yeah black
black should be ok here relief
yeah usually complicated stuff for the
Kings Indian four pawns okay thanks for
watching